you guys were having a debate earlier
yes the debate was is there communist
country
what would help me out with that debate
right there if there's a country around
the world that's communistic or not
because apparently apparently if the
name itself
yeah uh if they name themselves
communists that's not good enough for
for adam you know he says they're not a
communist even though it's uh what is
the republic
of the republic of china also known as
the ccp which is the party of china the
communist party of china so apparently
that's not enough
you know they don't identify as
communists even though they're
communists but let's define it actually
because let's define
what is 100 communism what is coming
should we should we look it up for our
followers yeah
what is communication communism the
definition of communism correct me wrong
was there's zero private ownership
zero everything is controlled by the
communism
okay so the yes a political theory
derived from karl marx advocating class
one leading to a society in which all
property is publicly owned and each
person works
and is paid according to their abilities
and needs so essentially
a classless society a hundred percent
tax
yeah okay now there is two sides to
communism right
one is control they tell you whatever to
do the other one is
on the business side economically uh
political right
china is politically yes communistic
economically
they're still allowing but at the same
time notice also what's happening with
china lately
if you get a little too big what are
they doing to jack mazu
you're getting a little too much void
say hey hey give us control back of this
so
at any point the difference between
there and here is
they can at any point come and take
control of any business they want to you
can't say nothing about it
they can come in and do it anytime we've
seen what they've been doing with jack
ma and everything they're doing with the
ant group
i totally agree all day long well but
the thing is that you said that
communism
venezuela did that there's actually
videos where there's a man because i was
speaking to vanessa right here which is
incredible part of the valuetainment
team
and and there's a video where where i
think it's chavez uh or maduro
he's literally going says what is that
oh they sell jewelry take it
what is that they do this take it that's
communism
that's that that's communism so to say
that doesn't exist
actually i think the champion oh what
just happened whoa
on the right side on the right side so
so to say that it doesn't exist
oh i'll get it there it is okay so to
say that it doesn't exist it's the
biggest guy we've had on this chair
maybe that's what's going on you know
it's crazy because
it's we've seen it in action as a matter
of fact the champions
of communism are from venezuela yeah
right i mean even
as well as an absolutely vanessa did
communism the right way
did they yes because they ruined the
country how do you get the richest
one of the richest countries in the
world with oil and literally ruin it
you know they have more money than they
have more oil than united states have
more oil than mexico and
by the way mexico is uh to a certain
extent you have a socialist president
right now which is amlo
and he's uh and uh that's that's just
insane so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye